ya hemos visto en varias ocasiones que
la glucólisis es el proceso mediante el
cual comenzamos con una molécula de
glucosa que es de hecho una molécula con
6 átomos de carbono y podemos romperla
en dos moléculas de piruvato en donde
cada una tiene 3 carbonos y al hacerlo
producimos 2 atp netos verdad y además
reducimos n además en n a de h verdad lo
que estamos haciendo es agregando un and
johnny duro y por ello es reducción
entonces en realidad este paso es
reducción déjenme escribirlo bien esto
es reducción
reducción muy bien y por supuesto
también tenemos agua y iones de
hidrógeno y luego nos preguntábamos qué
podría ocurrir después cierto y hablamos
mucho sobre la respiración celular y eso
es lo que ocurre en muchos organismos
incluidos nosotros y que de hecho eso me
sirve a mí para poder producir muchos
atp es en realidad está ocurriendo en mi
cuerpo ahorita mismo verdad y por eso es
que inhaló oxígeno porque el oxígeno se
necesita para que se lleve a cabo la
respiración celular pero en ocasiones no
hay suficiente oxígeno alrededor o puede
que haya organismos que simplemente no
usan el oxígeno o no o no realiza la
respiración celular y hemos visto un
ejemplo de ello y fue la fermentación
láctica verdad que es una forma de
reciclar estos nh es verdad vamos a
poder oxidar lo y regresar a n
y esta oxidación es la que vemos
esencialmente en la fermentación
entonces esto ocurre en la fermentación
y es un proceso de oxidación oxidación
muy bien entonces en particular en la
fermentación láctica hablamos de tomar
el piruvato para poder oxidar el nh y al
hacerlo del piruvato se convierte en
ácido láctico verdad y este proceso se
utiliza por ejemplo en la producción del
yogurt o de la col agria o que también
se le conoce como sauerkraut e incluso
ocurre en los músculos cuando no tienen
suficiente oxígeno puede ser por ejemplo
cuando cuando corres a toda velocidad o
cuando estás cargando algo muy muy muy
muy pero muy pesado en este caso muy
probablemente tus células realizan la
fermentación láctica pero ahora vamos a
hablar de otra forma de fermentación y
esta es
fermentación
y mentación
fermentación alcohólica
alcohólica
muy bien
ahí tenemos la fermentación alcohólica y
está digamos la fermentación alcohólica
cuando hablamos de ella en realidad
pensamos en el etanol que es el que se
encuentra en todas las bebidas
alcohólicas y de hecho este es el
proceso mediante el cual se obtiene el
alcohol y que también se emplea por
ejemplo cuando cuando se hace pan ok
entonces primero pensemos en la reacción
y luego hablaremos de donde puede ser
que te la hayas encontrado entonces
cuando terminamos la glucólisis tenemos
dos moléculas de piruvato por cada
molécula de glucosa y cada una de estas
moléculas de piruvato digamos el primer
paso que ocurre es que pierden su grupo
car box y lo que es este que tenemos por
aquí muy bien ese es el primer paso y
este paso es facilitado por la enzima
piruvato descarboxilasa muy bien en
realidad este nombre lo único que
digamos que significa es que puede se
quita un grupo car box y lo del piruvato
y puedes ver que cuando quitamos este
grupo formado por un carbono y dos
oxígenos eso nos va a dar dióxido de
carbono verdad el cual será liberado
entonces vamos a obtener dióxido de
carbono el cual será liberado y por
supuesto en realidad estoy emitiendo
muchos de los detalles verdad y lo que
nos queda de este otro lado
esencialmente déjenme ponerlo con otro
color lo que nos queda de este lado
esencialmente es el acetaldehído verdad
que de hecho aquí se ve mucho más claro
y completo ok
tenemos acetaldehído y luego en el
siguiente paso el acetaldehído puede ser
reducido ok puede ser reducido y una
forma de pensarlo es que he reducido
gracias al nh puede ser reducido gracias
al nh para convertirlo en etanol muy
bien vamos a obtener etanol y es un
mecanismo similar al que vimos en la
fermentación láctica cuando cuando
fuimos del piruvato hacia el ácido
láctico
ahora es el acetaldehído el que se
convierte en etanol entonces este paso
de aquí digamos de ir del acetaldehído
al etanol es un paso de reducción
entonces en este caso se redujo se
redujo muy bien en realidad gana un año
ni duró verdad y en el proceso de
reducirse por otro lado el nh el nh se
oxida en n además entonces en este caso
el dna de hc óxido
ok sido muy bien entonces el punto el
punto central de todo esto es que puedes
oxidar nh en línea de más para entrar de
nuevo a la glucólisis y como lo mencioné
en el vídeo anterior sobre la
fermentación láctica en realidad es una
pena porque el virus no tiene energía si
tuviéramos oxígeno podría entrar al
ciclo de krebs y obtener más energía
además el proceso de la oxidación del nh
en teoría puede usarse para obtener más
energía a través de la cadena de
transporte de electrones pero no estamos
haciendo eso en este caso estamos
realizando cualquiera de los dos tipos
de fermentación ya sea fermentación
alcohólica o fermentación láctica verdad
fermentación alcohólica o láctico al
menos este proceso de la fermentación
alcohólica ha resultado ser muy útil
para las civilizaciones humanas fíjense
vamos a ir a estas imágenes que tenemos
aquí esto que tenemos aquí abajo es
digamos el personaje más famoso cuando
hablamos de la fermentación
alcohólica y este de aquí este de aquí
este personaje en realidad es una célula
de levadura muy bien esta es una célula
de levadura levadura que está
clasificado como un hongo y tiene unos
pocos micrómetros de diámetro de este
esta esta célula tiene unos pocos
micrómetros de diámetro y las
variaciones de levadura se utilizan en
la producción de pan o de vino o de
varias bebidas alcohólicas como la
cerveza porque lo que hace la levadura
es digerir los azúcares verdad luego
luego realiza la glucólisis y se sigue
con la fermentación alcohólica lo que
hace al pan digamos esponjoso es digamos
a este pan que tenemos aquí es
justamente este paso donde donde el
grupo car box y lo se desprende del
piruvato verdad facilitado por la
piruvato de descarboxilasa y el dióxido
de carbono es liberado
entonces en este paso lo que lo que hace
es que el pan se vuelve esponjoso
digamos gracias a las burbujas que se
están haciendo pero también tenemos
etanol produciéndose así que dicho este
es un hecho bastante interesante de que
el pan puede tener restos de alcohol en
él verdad puede tener digamos el pan
puede tener restos de etanol verdad
algunos residuos de etanol y esto es
debido a que utilizamos la levadura para
esponjar el pan y esa levadura realiza
la glucólisis y luego la fermentación
alcohólica produciendo etanol por ello
es que podemos encontrar rastros de
etanol en el pan ahora por supuesto que
si hablamos de la producción de vino
verdad entonces el objetivo principal es
justamente obtener el etanol verdad
entonces de hecho lo vemos como la
bebida alcohólica tradicional así que la
levadura juega un papel muy importante
en nuestra sociedad